Pakistan plans to tighten its control of
Internet activity through a nationwide
web control system news outlet Coda's
story says it's gained exclusive access
to documents showing that Islamabad
contracted a Canadian company called
sand vine to help build the system the
surveillance infrastructure would
monitor all of the country's incoming
and outgoing Internet traffic CW's very
own Omar Ali was one of the reporters
who worked with Coda's story on the
investigation
boomer tell us a little bit more about
what you found yeah so I would start
with saying that this is an
unprecedented move in Pakistan in this
current environment and the system in
general aims at curbing great traffic
which some experts say might also
include encrypted messaging services
like whatsapp and they also say that
that equipment provided by sign wine is
capable of redirecting and blocking the
internet traffic in real time meaning
the government can essentially intercept
the Internet traffic at any point and
can do anything with it and like
previously in Egypt and Turkey in fact
the same technology has been used to
install spyware in the users devices and
I would also like to add that the same
technology which is which send wine is
providing in Pakistan has been used in
China as well where the government can
filter out certain keywords and the
content containing certain keywords and
block access to websites in real time so
and and and after after all of this the
system also raises concerns about
privacy because the government and some
private companies will now have access
to the Internet data from millions of
users in Pakistan now Pakistan is a
democracy but last year Voice of America
was blocked in the country and a few
times in the past we've seen YouTube
also blocked and most recently I believe
a committee to protect journalists a
member
was kicked out of the country what's
going on here yes the things have indeed
changed I would say drastically over the
last few years in Pakistan which as you
said is a democracy in principle but
critics say that the powerful military
in Pakistan is actually calling the
shots from behind the scenes and as you
pointed out press freedom and and
freedom of expression in general are are
onto in decline in Pakistan so people
are now really worried because for many
internet is perhaps the only source left
that remains relatively and uncensored
unlike the traditional news media and
sorry analysts actually believe yeah
well let's talk about authoritarian tech
in general you have a Canadian company
exporting to a democracy often we think
of China doing this kind of thing but
the surveillance tech business is a
global business isn't it yeah yeah I
think it's very striking indeed and and
it's very interesting to see a Canadian
company exporting its surveillance tools
to countries like Pakistan where the
freedom of expression is routinely
violated and send sand wine is in fact
indirectly linked to the same parent
company as the annus or group which is a
well known for its pegasus spying
software and in fact similar programs
have been used by several Middle Eastern
companies alike and and San vine and
other companies are happily they happily
profit off of selling their services to
these regimes in fact I would like to
add that sentiment publicly committed in
2012 to not work with the government of
Pakistan okay we found evidence
suggesting it was offering same service
as some services in Pakistan dating back
to at least 2016 Omar Ali thank you